So in quick summary, in this lesson I covered the basic concepts of how we
can take point processes, how computations at the pixel values, and
use that to add images, subtract images.
I showed you how to use this to be able to do simple processes on images.
Showed an example that by just doing this we actually can
learn more about transparency the alpha blending,
which is used commonly in image processing types of techniques.
Alpha blending is also widely used to be able to represent the transparency
layer which is actually another processing thing that can be used for
masking images.
And again, I showed an example of how we would use an image histogram and
all of the statistics that come with it to help but
look at images a little bit more carefully.
In next class, what we will do is now we will look at not just pixels.
So, you know, we were so far concentrating on images where each index is known.
We had an image.
And I looked at a pixel.
Of course, so far in this case we took another image that had a pixel.
But now we want to also start looking at is what happens in
the neighborhood around the pixels.
And that will let us introduce us to the concept of convolution and correlation.
Look forward to it.